Let's go next to undress from Saragossa in
Spain, right?
How's it going, David?
Hey, how are you?
Pretty good, pretty good.
I have more of a generalized kind of hypothesis
in general, more than really something specific
to our politics.
All right.
I'll go for a generalized hypothesis in general.
Yeah, for sure, it's it's basically the idea
that success in in politics at all kind of
breeds corruption.
So if if you're if your platform is that you
are specifically not corrupt, that you are,
for example, we'll say Bernie Sanders, whether
or not you think Bernie Sanders is actually
corrupt is neither here nor there.
But a lot of his campaign is he's not funded
by the billionaires.
You know that he is very trying to show that
he is not corrupt.
But platforms like that usually just don't
just get stomped out by people who are being
paid off, more people who are more corrupt.
Right.
Because.
Yeah, because success breeds corruption in
politics.
It's basically my idea there.
So you kind of cut in and out there, but basically
I agree with you in the bigger sense, which
is, as I've said before, counting on the people
who got elected under the current system to
completely change the system is a long shot
because they themselves are at risk of being
taken out of power if they change the system
that got them into power.
Does that sort of make sense as a general
principle?
Certainly.
Yeah.
So one of the ways that I think this could
change would be term limits, because if you
term limit people where there is no advantage,
there's no let me go back.
There's less of an obvious incentive for them
to keep the system that worked for them in
place, because either way, they're going to
be term limited.
I think maybe we would get more people really
willing to to radically change the system
that got them elected.
That's one idea that I think would help.
Oh, that's that's that's absolutely great.
It's because I see things like, oh, I forgot
how many it is, but Mitch McConnell is like
so many Senate terms and it's absolutely ridiculous,
right?
No.
Yeah, absolutely.
Term limits just across the board is definitely
a step in the right direction.
But yeah, absolutely.
I just think the just the general just the
way the the system is created is is just.
Yeah.
It's just naturally breeds corruption and
stuff like that no doubt generally represent
the people that are supposed to be representing
and you know, Republicans and the covid bill
recently is a very good example of that.
No question.
Yeah, no question.
I think you're thinking about this exactly.
Exactly the way I am.
Absolutely.
Well, thank you very much, David.
So so you live in Spain, but you're an American?
No, my my dad was actually in the US Air Force,
so he met my mom in Spain.
Right now, I am actually living in Nebraska,
if you'll believe that.
So you tricked me into thinking this was a
more interesting call by saying you were in
Saragossa.
I'm originally from South Dakota, but Button
I right now I'm not living there, no.
All right, well,
we'll allow it.
It strikes me as a little dishonest, but we'll
allow it.
OK, sorry.
All right, thank you.
OK, great, take care.
Thank you.
No, I appreciate the call.
Very important issue.
We are counting on the people who benefit
from the system to change the system.
In some sense, that makes no sense.
All right, let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, do not hang up, because
I'm going right back to the phones momentarily